like my dad used to say when I asked if
he was proud of me hey let's talk about
sports the NBA Finals started on
Thursday and in Game two last night the
Golden State Warriors beat the Cleveland
LeBron James now I've been suspicious of
the NBA ever since I first learned of
their nefarious plot to force jazz on
the people of Utah but the NBA is now so
progressive that it's not just one of my
enemies like fiber and dogs with human
names no the NBA deserves an even more
evil title nemesis and I can't expose a
threat this big without a teammate so
let's bring in citizen journalist Tim
Balz thanks Jordan
so psyched to be on your squad
I said don't bring the ball I said don't
bring the ball on set you need to put
that away don't worry I won't play with
it I put it away fine now sim the NBA
has become a total abomination to
American values tell me I'm right
big-time j-dog instead of shutting up
and bawling hard these rock pounders
have become mouthpieces of progressive
politics there are teams wearing I can't
breathe shirts and players giving
speeches about police violence Plus
LeBron James call president Trump's
views laughable and scary that's treason
the only two adjectives acceptable for
our president are sexy and oops
I already said sexy I guess it's just
one adjective ma needs to respond to
these protests the way the NFL is going
to by fining teams and that'll really
sting because NFL owners are notoriously
poor but of course goody two-shoes
Warriors coach Steve Kerr had to stick
his nose in the NFL's business it's
idiotic but that's how the NFL has
handled their business
understands patriotism in America is
about free speech about peacefully
protesting patriotism in America isn't
about protesting no no no it's about
fireworks and eagles and the EPA letting
us use fireworks to shoot down Eagles
yeah there are a bunch of leggy
limousine liberals plus they've been
infiltrated by globalists yeah literally
more than a fifth of the league is now
foreign-born players from 42 countries
and territories and they're avoiding
technical fouls by swearing in their
native tongues it's disgraceful
I mean what's to stop some french guy
from saying but Pauly le peace Lisa
Cunha I have no clue what that means
which makes it even more offensive yeah
big time it means go jerk off at the
grocery store you dirty asshole
very long story behind how I know that
basically I was standing outside I've
got a move on Wednesday I got a move on
move on move on right keep it moving the
point is the league is trying to tell us
these foreigners are good for the game
but that's just globalist spin no doubts
that oh no no no no don't know just hold
and you need to hold it with two hands
to hold it all right hold it hold can
you move on move on to women and hell
they're ruining basketball oh are they
great okay yeah not only does the NBA
have the first female assistant coach in
major league sports Becky Hammon they
also were the first professional sport
with not one but three female referees
I mean besides major league soccer yes
oh yeah they were the first professional
sport exactly yeah
female RAF's Jordan think about it women
are whistling at men there's still a to
our construction site moves female refs
is a bad call if I wanted a woman to
tell me I'd done something wrong I get
married and exposure to my personal
habits sorry but these gals aren't
getting a pad no pet don't know they're
not getting a pet don't know so no no
I'm the issue of them being in they're
not oh you don't just just you know
let's just just just go just do finish
just just finish this segment okay all
right
so the NBA actually stands for national
bata Association because the players
have gotten softer than good toilet
paper we take a look at these
Jordan the NBA is wine addiction MPA
players that they like their wine okay
these guys are students of the game and
you're their kind of students are the
grape these days stars like Kyrie Irving
and Damian Lillard have gone vegan or
vegetarian in the past year to help them
perform on court I was always looking
for an edge both on and off the court
that was gonna get me having my
profession and in life and I thought
yoga was really the right thing to do
Jesus Kevin love's about to gentrify
half courts
yeah at the end of the finals the coach
is going to get showered with a cooler
full of kombu chips yeah yeah that's a
yeast infection just waiting the
halfback here's what's worse that in
spite of all these namaste implants
chopped and wide sniffers the NBA's
ratings are now at a four-year high and
it doesn't track it's like the more
progressive the league gets the more
popular it becomes free thinkers yeah we
need to shut this nemesis down yes then
the other sports can steal their view no
don't know and then the networks will
block those stop it no just that Trump
can fool know until the advertisers oh
stop it boss the fight continues the
fight
[Applause]
[Music]